crash just a few miles off the strip
leaving one man dead and an apartment
building fully evacuated that crash
happening near maryland parkway and
desert inn police say a speeding driver
slammed into a home right there madison
kimbrough on the story all day live on
scene after talking to neighbors madison
this area of desert in maryland parkway
is no strangers to cars zipping by at
all hours of the day you'll actually
hear some workers are still assessing
this area in today's crash just another
reminder of how dangerous speeding can
be to those living nearby
the black vehicle that you see over
there
embedded in the structure was traveling
at a high rate of speed westbound here
on desert end
somewhere along the way and the driver
lost control
he left the roadway and impacted the
structure a life lost in an instant as a
speeding driver collides right into the
wall of these desert inn apartments the
crash happening around 4 monday
afternoon the driver found dead on scene
as police evacuated the neighbors due to
the building inspector deeming the
complex unsound speeding along desert
inn a chronic problem says resident jody
templeton we just heard a really large
crash
but again that's kind of a common thing
around here so it's already a 45 mile an
hour speed limit which people
go into excess of that quite often
we've had plenty of people crash into
our walls
we've had to repair them several times
residents of the complex who live right
upstairs from where the crash occurred
says they immediately felt the impact
luckily not getting hurt in the process
a split second
everything happened like
everything was like shaking like holy
hell was that a bomb that like i thought
like and after that i went like i went
downstairs and i saw like everything
happened like the car and stuff but the
good thing is there was no one inside
like below us campio says the damage to
his apartment was mild with a crack in
the wall but even so he and his family
were told to evacuate immediately
again other than the driver no one else
was hurt in the crash and the red cross
is assisting in those that have been
displaced as i said you can hear the
workers are still here assessing the
situation reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now